they put a Bible verse things all over
their merch to John 3 16. they have it
under the cup they have it on the bag
they have it on the everything that's
kind of tired so if you say Give me
animal style this little little tip
they will give you grilled onions
[Music]
okay since we all
live in L.A I thought it'd be nice to
share with you guys except oh wait yeah
right here baby don't anymore hey this
is still home I grew up here not to me
you just owned it I just about I'm gonna
go ahead and tell you guys seven
things that you may not know about in
and out oh cool I'll tell you something
all right there's a secret secret menu
they put Bible verse things all over
their merch to John 316. they have it
under the cup they have it on a bag they
have it on the everything that's kind of
tired so if you say Give me animal style
this little little tip
they will give you grilled onions
and thousand island dressing all right
so here's some stuff you don't here's
some stuff you don't know
a double double is two patties
[Laughter]
what else you got for us sure here's a
here's a cool thing you know the Special
Sauce that they have on there on the
burgers that's the Thousand Island
dressing yeah the Special Sauce it
hasn't changed since 1948 it's the same
exact formula it's just thousand island
dressing if it ain't broke down is it is
it just thousand island dressing they do
like relish they do chop relish they do
like Mayo
ketchup a thick mustard and then like
red vinegar if it's just Thousand Island
then people wouldn't be busting their
ass trying to copy it no it's definitely
it's definitely a little bit more than
just thousands well that actually might
just be Thousand Islands Ryan Ryan I
have a question it's probably covered in
it's probably covered in the article
when they say like they're trying to
figure out they're trying to crack the
recipe Why isn't scientists just analyze
what's in there
right I think maybe it's one of those
things where you can find the
ingredients but you can't find how much
yeah the quantities dude I just told you
guys right now and also the prep the
preparation maybe the order I just gave
the secret away but I mean you can get a
job there and steal but then they don't
make the sauce there I don't think you
could get a job at the factory but still
it boom like Coca-Cola how that they
always go like oh they haven't grabbed
the recipe it's like
how often they cracked the [__]
recipe put a man on the moon you can't
get the [__] recipe
it's just Cola I know but I heard that
they keep it in the vault and only like
two people know I don't know maybe
that's just a myth like a legend it
sounds like one soundtrack
Oreo made uh what is it called when you
have like a doomsday thing
yeah they made it they made a thing for
Oreo where they had the recipe and some
cookies just in case something happens
in the world someone can sell it there's
like this box that's cool and it'll
it'll save it let's make cookies before
rebuilding ours you don't like Oreos oh
really we don't need cookies while we're
rebuilding we can't do both we need
sustenance you don't like Oreos cool wow
I didn't even know I was gonna be so
Italian Oreos
you know what I wish just like Oreos
I wish before this whole like um seed
oil [__] came where everyone's like I
don't want lard no cholesterol I wonder
what things tasted like during our
grandparents like [__] yeah because they
fried things in lard they make cookies
and all that stuff in large dude they
didn't use [__] canola oil they use
beef fat they die when they're 48. but
it was worth it it probably tastes
really good probably was yeah yeah if I
lived give me the good life uh here's
another thing did you know in and out
was the very first drive-through
hamburger restaurant that's tight the
first and you know the it's the first
ones here in Baldwin Park right here is
it that was the first one the one yeah
there's a there's a [__] headquarters
right down here oh we should have got in
and out for lunch the original yeah we
messed up yeah it was just the uh it was
10 feet wide
the original location dude internet was
the best this is the only place you can
get like a full meal for two people for
like 18 bucks dude it's still so cheap
yeah like it's still bad take I don't
really like in and out oh you don't like
cookies
I don't like it is because of their
their buns you don't like the Buns
everything else I like but they're I
don't like their fries kind of a bunny
like I like a brioche
I think the fries suck cardboard they
they do suck yeah
you ever get a double fries don't hang
on the Buns get a fry well the buns are
a little dry they toast them it's like
perfect perfect texture you know what's
you know what's weird is that okay the
fries do the fries do match the burgers
well but I don't think they're good by
themselves yeah exactly I never not like
a McDonald's fry yeah no no McDonald's
fries you could get it by a Donald fry
Top Notch that's inside the Ark of the
Covenant is filled with those McDonald
Coke and fries McDonald's don't they
have their own like freaking that's what
I found out from Bart yeah we'll see you
know what I think McDonald's would do
really well huh if they had chili fries
chili fries yeah I don't see that feels
ethnic and I don't like it
keep it all American man
that was the most popular item was chili
cheese fries and it was always girls
that bought chili cheese fries when you
worked in yeah [__] love Chili's
cheese fries I love chili cheese fries
because they share it Nikki loves them
rock your guts I'm telling you it does
and it was always girls love getting
their guts right I heard that it was
always like very petite ladies so we'll
get it and they'd smash it bro how much
do you think the original In-N-Out
hamburger cost when it first opened yeah
closed captioning not available
in and they give it to you oh you know
what they still do that in Pasadena the
[__] pharmacy oh the Fair Oaks one
yeah uh where they like do the make it
yeah because you used to go to the uh
you'd get sodas at the pharmacy
um
yeah it was 10 cents too for that drink
the good old days used to have people
pump your gas too yeah oh yeah and in
and out so the guy um Harry Schneider
the guy who started you know is actually
the guy who invented the two-way speaker
for drive-throughs oh interesting that's
crazy right that's a crazy invention is
it like at the park you know when you're
a kid you can talk to your friend in
that little horn and then they could
hear you oh the one that's like stuck to
the ground
and then you're like hey hey can you
hear me yeah I can hear you but tell me
why if he invented the two-way speaker
they don't even do speaker anymore they
got people standing out there yeah they
just completely trash people are always
yelling in the [__] speaker and the
poor person taking the orders like Jesus
I think they're just trying to
the line yeah
they are they do the speaker and then
the cars behind them can order get more
speakers yeah yeah get more speakers
a speaker for each do you think he makes
royalties off other drive-throughs using
it if he's still alive you know what you
know what no you died a state doesn't
get it you know when you're watching
like a football game or whatever or
soccer match you see those lines on the
field that are like drawn on the field
yeah the yellow lines I actually think
that was real yeah dude that is a guy
owns the patent for that and he charges
like 80 G's a game or some [__] he's
stacking racks
we should have been inventors huh we
[__] up big dogs like it's too late
do you make people laugh you don't get
paid die poor nobody gives a [__] you
care about the world and they call you
stupid you call your idiots online what
do you think the original in and out
logo was
it was the guy no oh that's McDonald's
who's the guy because the McDonald's had
the guide with the round face yeah yeah
it's Speedy so they didn't you know how
like you see that yellow arrow that
wasn't there until 1954. so that's six
years after it just used to be the red
sign yeah
and then they added the arrow and it
hasn't really changed in and out
the drive-through the first one but you
guys think
sorry what were you saying
what were you saying Nick just had a
really smart thing to say Nick had an
epiphany I was like in and out first
drive through
it all makes sense yeah no no this area
the arrow is the lowest Colleen Did It
Colleen didn't yeah I didn't register
she needed anything maybe it was about
the process of eating food out it goes
in and then out yeah
I was trying to hook her up because she
wasn't understanding it's a digestive
thing yeah I still don't get it yeah but
it's okay we'll figure it out okay we'll
figure it out I think if you grow up
with in and out you do get kind of like
tired of it in a way I got tired of it
because it was the cheapest way to get
calories 100 and it's healthy because
versus going to like in other places you
could pound some meat because you know
when people visit Cali back outside
and they want to go to in and out and
they like love it and then you're just
like okay cool we can go my [__] is
Shake Shack I like shakes I like Shake
Shack too because it's new but like
people that grew up with Shake Shack
like in and out oh really yeah the
internets are the most slammed of the
ones by the airport because of that [__]
it's like we just got the plane from
LaGuardia I just can't do it with the
lines like that's the only thing that
stops me I think the food's great but
the line is not worth it they [__] up
all traffic wherever they're at because
it's just it's a nightmare because you
have cars all the way into the streets
Chick-fil-A did too
and people still in the line don't
understand how it [__] works for some
reason you always get one guy who enters
the line and tries to cut everybody it's
like bro yeah yeah yeah have you been
here before the light especially
especially when there's like you're
talking about the ones where it goes
straight into the driveway and then a
guy comes to this side and just like
Waits and then everyone's like excuse me
he he's cutting you know they do that I
you know I've waited for uh in an
outline once and I I parked by because
the one that's by my house it's like a
Long Street and I was sitting behind a
car and I was like I was like damn this
[__] is not moving it was a long line
and I realized that the car was [__]
parked for like five minutes and I was
like I wasn't even the right [__]
line
and that's why it's called in and out
because it's drive through oh yeah yeah
it makes a lot more sense now
[Music]
foreign